candystore.com out with its interactive  map of all 50 states favorite Halloween  candies you can scroll over the map and  find your state here in Nevada I find  this very hard to believe but the top  candy is Hot Tamales no it's not yeah  followed by Hershey mini bars Hershey's  Kisses Nationwide now see this is where  Brian and I come in Reese's Reese's Cups  oh absolutely Uno followed by Skittles  in second place then Eminem's taking  third I can never remember Ted what's  that candy you like is it chicken sticks  chicken stick  if you interview a hundred Southern  Nevada kids you said Reese's knickers  KitKat or Hot Tamales no no no no no no  we're saying that study is hinky